madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir une
crise politique grave vient d'éclater en
grande bretagne monsieur harold wilson
le premier ministre le leader du parti
travailliste actuellement au pouvoir
monsieur harold wilson démission la
nouvelle est tombée en fin de matinée à
la surprise bien sûr la grande bretagne
n'est pas dans une situation brillante
c'est vrai qu'après une relative
accalmie les prix vont de nouveau flambé
qu'il ya là bas un million et demi de
chômeurs que la productivité de ceux qui
travaillent est l'une des plus faibles
de l'occident que la livre a atteint la
semaine dernière son niveau le plus bas
mais finalement tout cela n'est pas très
nouveau et ce n'est même pas à mettre
entièrement au passif de l'équipe
gouvernementale actuelle
alors pourquoi monsieur harold wilson
s'en va t'il qui va lui succéder
les élections vont elles être avancée
essayons de répondre à ces questions
il est important que je précise bien
pourquoi je démissionne j'ai été leader
de ce parti pas non plus de 13
stimulante et turbulente année dont près
de 8 au gouvernement un période premier
ministre a duré plus longtemps que celle
de n'importe lequel de mes prédécesseurs
en temps de guerre il est de mon devoir
envers le pays envers le parti de ne pas
occuper cette fonction de façon à
empêcher d'autres à se porter candidat à
ce poste
autre raison à ma démission mon
successeur doit prendre ses fonctions de
manière imposition si stupéfiante sortie
sans doute la chose la plus
spectaculaire qu'il est fait dans sa vie
politique un député quelque peu
sarcastique a commenté en ces termes le
départ du premier ministre à la chambre
des communes ce matin pendant quelques
minutes on a cru à un gag un poisson
d'avril prématurée et puis il a fallu se
rendre à l'évidence
harold wilson donne vraiment sa
démission démission qu'il justifie ainsi
en substance il est temps de passer la
main à un homme nouveau
démentant les rumeurs selon lesquelles
il était malade
le premier ministre a réaffirmé cet
après midi au cours d'une conférence de
presse que sa décision avait été prise
depuis bien longtemps et que la reine
avait été informé de ses intentions dès
la fin de l'année
dernière harold wilson qui a fêté la
semaine dernière son 60e anniversaire
s'était juré paraît-il de quitter la vie
politique à ces tâches précisément quoi
qu'il en soit ce départ plonge des
anglais dans la plus grande perplexité
et ravive une inquiétude déjà l'attend
face à une situation économique précaire
dès l'annoncé de cette démission la
livre sterling a accentué sa baisse et
on a enregistré le même phénomène au
stock exchange la bourse de londres
alors que va-t-il se passer dans les
tout prochains jours le groupe
parlementaire travailliste devra élire
un nouveau leader qui automatiquement
deviendra premier ministre mais le parti
travailliste est plus que jamais
tiraillée entre la gauche et les modérés
et la bataille sera rude
trois successeurs possibles pour
l'instant monsieur callaghan ministre
des affaires étrangères domicile est
ministre des finances et rock jenkins
munissent de l'intérieur face à un
gouvernement désarçonner les
conservateurs ont retrouvé toute leur
vigueur et margaret thatcher tout à
l'heure aux communes a demandé à ce que
l'on procède à des élections générales
hypothèse exclue pour l'instant car le
successeur de wilson disposera d'une
très maigre majorité mais il est
probable que d'ici à la fin de l'année
ces élections soit inévitable
en effet dès le mois de décembre
ron wilson avait informé la reine
d'angleterre de son intention de
démissionner à supposer qu'il ait mis au
courant sa femme que l'on voit ici avec
lui tout de suite après la conférence de
presse de cet après midi deux personnes
seulement savaient que wilson voulait
démissionner ce goût du secret n'est pas
circonstancielle
ils procèdent une attitude générale qui
a guidé wilson tout au long de sa
carrière malgré des aspects bonhomme il
cherchait souvent le contact avec la
foule toujours dur est en compagnie de
sa femme malgré cet aspect direct et
simple donc wilson selon l'avis de ses
plus proches collaborateurs livre est
rarement le font ses pensées cette
possibilité de dissimulation lui a
permis de se maintenir 13 ans à la tête
d'un parti travailliste souvent divisés
si ce n'est déchiré et huit ans non
consécutifs à la tête du gouvernement
en conclusion on peut dire que wilson a
dû faire face à des problèmes plus
impressionnant aucun autre cabinet de
l'histoire anglaise
d'après guerre l'avait connu l'un des
plus importants et l'inflation qui
restera à coup sûr la principale tâche
de son successeur le franc aujourd'hui
va un peu mieux qu'hier et puisqu'il
s'agit d'une monnaie qui flotte
disons que le franc est aujourd'hui en
haut de la vague mouvement de hausse
sans doute passagers et qui s'explique
par un phénomène technique qui mérite
d'être expliquée en deux mots la semaine
dernière des gens bien informés ou ayant
comme on dit du nez ont vendu des
millions de francs qu'il détenait et ont
acheté des marques et des dollars d'où
la baisse du franc hier et aujourd'hui
ces mêmes gens ont racheté des franc
dévalué donc moins cher réalisant au
passage un joli bénéfice
d'où la hausse du franc constaté ce
matin c'est ça la spéculation réalisé
pour une large part sur le dos de la
collectivité pour connaître la véritable
valeur du franc dégagé de ses mouvements
spéculatifs
il faut attendre je crois deux ou trois
semaines au moins plusieurs experts
monétaire estime que le franc se situera
à cinq ou six pour cent en dessous de sa
valeur des derniers mois simple
pronostics depuis hier depuis qu'a été
connue la décision du gouvernement
français de faire flotter notre monnaie
les commentateurs en france comme à
l'étranger s'intéresse en premier lieu
aux conséquences politiques de ce qu'ils
considèrent souvent comme un échec de
valéry giscard d'estaing la france
montrée du doigt ses voisins lui en
veulent d'avoir touché à l'europe
c'est un pas en arrière écrit le journal
la libre belgique
la france a cédé à des réflexes
nationalistes renchérit le journal de
genève est très vite nos confrères
attaque valéry giscard d'estaing lui
même ce flottement du franc c'est la
défaite d'une ambition giscardienne dit
le journal italien corriere della siega
qui faisant l'amalgamé avec les
cantonales parle de semaine noire pour
le président français qui fait penser au
titre de libération week end noir pour
giscard même si les 1000 études entre le
titre de la tribune de lausanne
giscard profil bas avec celui du
quotidien de paris
giscard au dessous de la barre
voilà en vrac une revue de presse van
asch et qui bouscule passablement valéry
giscard d'estaing sans qu'il l'ait
vraiment voulu le chef de l'état s'est
trouvé en première ligne les critiques
des passants très vite les fonctions de
jacques chirac et jean pierre fourcade
or giscard ne veut pas esquivé fidèle à
sa tradition
il veut d'abord s'expliquer et c'est ce
qu'il va faire dans huit jours à la
télévision
le ton sera sans doute celui de la
dédramatisation mais à tout hasard une
organisation de combat contre la gauche
met en place
pierre juillet l'éminence grise le
stratège sous pompidou revient à
matignon auprès de jacques chirac
le dispositif à double face de la
majorité ne devrait pas tarder à se
manifester
un élément patrick qui devrait
contribuer à soutenir le franc le
déficit de la balance commerciale en
février a été moins important qu'en
janvier à 1% près la france équilibre
ses achats à l'étranger et ses ventes à
l'étranger cette amélioration n'aura
toutefois de signification que si elle
se confirme au cours des prochains mois
c'était à prévoir dans les dix huit
usines françaises du groupe
rhône-poulenc textile il ya eu
aujourd'hui des mouvements de grève avec
occupation des locaux par le personnel
il y a quelques jours vous en souvenez
peut-être nous vous avions présenté un
reportage réalisé dans l'une des grandes
usines de ce groupe à vaulx en velin
à travers ce reportage on sentait bien
que le climat se détériorer dans cette
entreprise
l'une des plus grandes de l'industrie
française celle annonces de plusieurs
centaines de licenciements dans l'une
des usines du groupe qui a provoqué ce
mouvement de grève
on savait depuis longtemps que le groupe
rhône-poulenc se trouvait confronté à de
graves problèmes financiers pourtant
pourtant il aura fallu un temps de la
séance extraordinaire du comité
d'entreprise de l'usiné de péage de
roussillon pour prendre une juste mesure
des difficultés l'annoncent officielle
du licenciement de 515 personnes sur un
effectif global de 8 160 employés
immédiatement les travailleurs de
l'ensemble du groupe textile se sont
mises en grève défilé dans les rues à
péage de roussillon on est même allé
jusqu'à séquestrer deux patrons pendant
quelques heures
selon la direction les autres
travailleurs de l'usiné de péage n'ont
rien à craindre ils seront soit reclassé
dans la branche chimie soit mise à la
pré-retraite
les syndicats eux refusent tout
licenciement ils affirment qu'ils ont
prévenu la direction il ya de cela trois
ans de la nécessité de reconvertir les
personnels de la production d'acétate
parce que le problème il est là
lusine de péage de roussillon produits
de là c'est à tort pour là c'est à cause
de la crise
rien ne va plus park en france
d'ailleurs en allemagne et en suisse
romand poulin qui a déjà dû réduire ses
effectifs et en angleterre le concurrent
numéro un à issia a décidé de licencier
purement et simplement 30 % de son
personnel
il n'empêche rhône poulenc apparaît de
plus en plus comme un colosse aux pieds
d'argile
une entreprise qui repose entièrement
sur les épaules d'un seul homme
renault gilles les syndicats de leur
côté sont prêts distille à envisager de
nouvelles formes d'action pour obliger
la direction et à travers elle les
pouvoirs publics à renoncer à ce qu'ils
appellent une politique de sous emploi
c'est demain qu'ont lieu les marées
d'équinoxe elle compte parmi les plus
fortes de l'année puisque dans la manche
sur les côtes de bretagne la plus forte
marée atteindra les coefficients 110
haies dans l'île d'ouessant
c'est avec l'inquiétude et même avec de
l angoisse que les habitants attendent
ce phénomène naturel
ce n'est pas l'amplitude de la marée qui
leur fait peur ils en ont vu d'autres
ce qu'ils craignent c'est que dans son
mouvement irrésistible la mer à chef de
briser le pétrolier olympic braveraient
libérant les centaines de tonnes de
pétrole qu'il contient encore mais
retraçons d'abord les principales phases
de ce naufrage
l'olympique brave rice et ce pétrolier
de 275 mille tonnes de la compagnie
onasis échouées sur la côte nord
d'ouessant 333 mètres de longueur 67 m
auteur de la kia la cheminée pourtant
cet énorme bateau n'a pas résisté à la
tempête de samedi dernier il s'est cassé
en deux tous les marins de l'île le dit
c'était prévisible la mer est mauvaise
en cette période de l'année et les
marées atteint ici leur plus fort
coefficient
forte heureusement le bateau était à
vide il ne contenait que 12 100 tonnes
de mazout nécessaires à sa propulsion et
c'est peut-être en raison de cette
faible quantité que les responsables
n'ont pas agi tout de suite
l'autre raison possible la nationalité
étrangère du bateau et la complexité du
droit maritime qui devait prendre les
premières mesures d'urgence pour
vidanger les soutes la compagnie
propriétaire ou les assureurs
aujourd'hui on sait que ce sont les
assurances qui paieront d'abord le
bateau 27 milliards de centimes auxquels
s'ajouteront les dégâts causés par la
pollution du navire là encore il faudra
du temps et les 12 cents habitants
d'ouessant sont en colère non je vois
comment doit on faire contrôler tout ça
c'est anormal
elle se réduit vitu vidanger auparavant
par dia du vote ont eu du beau temps le
bazou peut citer payables le maire le
maire l'a demandé à la préfecture
db l'administration nul et là la mère de
mon deux mois en brûlant il a marché
pour tout voir à moins de douze jours ce
sont les mêmes quoi ils veulent en venir
à bout et tout marche à bord vu que ces
baisers des cibles visées il fallait que
ça dure ail blanc provient bien rabotés
de quoi passe à côté
il fait des bonds dans certaines creek
de la côte nord d'ouessant la couche
d'hydrocarbure atteint plusieurs
centimètres d et peuvent en provenance
du pétrolier émergent morceaux de bois
bidon débris de canaux une pellicule
grâce à mener par les embruns s'est
déposée dans les prés où paissent les
moutons les ouessantins sont indignés
hier le commandant du pétrolier échoué
les accusés de pillages aujourd'hui
c'est le spectacle de cette marée noire
la première qui ait jamais connue l'île
mais c'est dommage de voir la plus belle
page de livre
vachon non la cote c'est la plus jolie
n'y pense vous avez vu vers le bas par
tous les poissons on en trouvera les
grèves sont sûrement quelques pêcheurs
il reste trois ou quatre professionnels
et je pense qu'ils vont faire
je n'aime pas
voilà la grosse erreur
au classement des lois je vous assure
des six bateaux avec
échoué et babol d'une place importante à
la crise et a longtemps été enlevés ou
de mazout et bateaux situation avec le
déclenchement du plan polmar pollution
maritime les secours vont s'organiser
déjà 4 dragueur de la marine nationale
s'emploie à réduire les plaques de
mazout situé au large de la côte
d'autre part une centaine de soldats du
6e régiment du génie d'angers sont
attendus demain avec l'aide des
volontaires de lille
ils vont participer au nettoyage de
cette côte des barrages anti-pollution
sont prévus également
reste une inconnue les effets de cette
grande marée d'équinoxe prévu aussi pour
demain qui peut rendre au nul
ses premiers travaux veillée d'armes à
saint-etienne demain à cette heure nous
serons à cinq minutes du commencement du
match retour qui opposera l'équipe
stéphanoise à l'équipe de kiev
le trois-mâts dernier en union
soviétique lester soit stéphanois
avaient été dominés et avait dû
encaisser de but est ce à dire que tout
espoir est perdu pour saint-etienne de
triompher et d'aller plus loin dans ce
championnat d'europe des clubs
vainqueurs de coupe
on ne le crois pas les verts sont en
effet coutumier de ces rétablissement de
dernière heure on l'a vu lorsque battue
par l'équipe du split de yougoslavie par
4 1 il devait sur leur terrain cette
fois écrasé cette même équipe par 5 1
pourquoi pas le même exploit demain pour
nous remettre dans l'ambiance revoyons
le déroulement des deux but encaissé il
ya quinze jours par saint-etienne en
urss
lors de ce premier match comptant pour
le quart de finale de la coupe d'europe
les stéphanois auront donc deux but à
remonter demain soir au stade geoffroy
guichard face au dynamo de kiev s'ils
veulent se qualifier pour les demi
finales de la coupe d'europe comme l'an
passé les deux buts marqués par cocof et
bloque king si l'on était heureux ou
traduit une domination manifeste des
soviétiques pour la première fois depuis
leur grande aventure européenne de ces
dernières années les stéphanois n'ont
pas marqué de but sur terrain adverse
pire ils ont terriblement déçu sur le
plan technique pourtant l'un de leurs
points forts demain il devrait en être
tout autrement dans le stade geoffroy
guichard souvent transformé en enfer
pour les équipes adverses
près de quarante mille personnes qui
seront
on les verts comme on dit sur les bus de
kiev en espérant une nouvelle
qualification en solo ce qu'on peut
craindre c'est que l'équipe de kiev
conserve bien le ballon et arrive à
trouver l'ouverture sur des contres il
faudra se montrer extrêmement prudents
sur les adversaires qui seront en pointe
c'est-à-dire blocs qui n'est
onichtchenko probablement et puis
essayer de faire un pressing constant
sur tous les autres joueurs de façon à
les perturber
et ça c'est une arme à double tranchant
si ça réussit et que nous puissions
marquer un but dans les premières
minutes automatiquement à ce moment là
tout est remis en question et l'équipe
qu'elle risque de perdre son sang froid
par contre si en faisant ce pressing
nous prenons un but sur un contre alors
là ce sera extrêmement difficile pour
leur ultime répétition
les stéphanois ont eu un match très dur
face à lui ce jeudi dernier s'ils ont
réussi le match nul grâce à l' arbitre
monsieur murs ils ont suivi le match
alors que demain il faudra le prendre en
main c'est surtout la ligne d'attaqué
stéphanoise qui inquiète un peu elle ne
vient qu'en dixième position et
meilleure attaque du championnat de
france et ne compte presque
exclusivement que sur dominique rostock
dominique rocheteau s'il peut jouer et
on l'espère bien sûr on a peut-être du
renfort à des christian sarramagna le
numéro 11 de saint-etienne qui pourrait
lui aussi inquiéter les défenseurs
soviétique les éloigner des terrains
depuis six mois
il manquera peut-être de compétition et
de toute façon il faudra grand très
grand saint-etienne au venir à bout de
kiev 2
saint-etienne fera l'impossible
maintenant il ne faut pas oublier que
l'équipe de kiev est une équipe assez
exceptionnel qui représente l'équipe de
l'urss donc je crois que nos chances
lors de son prénom mais l'important
c'est de les jouer
nos militaires vont donc changer de
tenue ainsi on a décidé leur grand
patron le ministre de la défense
monsieur yvon bourges il s'agit
d'adapter l'uniforme aux conceptions
modernes de l'habillement pour ne pas
dire à la mode un grand concours vient
d'être lancée auprès des professionnels
de l'habillement masculin afin qu'ils
proposent des figurines susceptibles de
correspondre à ce que peut attendre un
jeune soldat en 1976 pierre cardin yves
saint laurent et d'autres personnalités
moins connus de la couture la haute
couture ont été sollicités aucune
directive précise ne leur a été donné
afin que leur esprit créatif puisse se
donner à fond
c'est fin juin que le jury de ce
concours se prononcera
quelle est la première idée qui me vient
à l'esprit quand on dit tenue de sortie
pour un militaire confort le gars qui
sort se retrouve dans un vêtement un
vêtement de confort moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que le confort n'était pas la
qualité première des tenues de sortie
qui ont marqué les grandes époques de
l'histoire de france
selon l'humeur des tailleurs du roi on
insistait sur le chapeau sur les tissus
sur les broderies ou sur la forme ou
selon la volonté des tailleurs de la
république sur le pantalon ou les
boutons de guêtre en fait les français
au fil des siècles ont vu de toutes les
couleurs en allant voir défiler l'armée
française aujourd'hui grandes décisions
la tenue de sortie des trois cent trente
mille soldats de l'armée de terre va
changer on ne sait pas encore ce qu'elle
sera mais cela va changer c'est le
monsieur bourges et le général bigeard
qu'ils l'armée demande aux
professionnels de l'habillement de lui
proposer des idées une sorte de concours
dont ouvert aussi bien aux tailleurs
anonymes ou grands couturiers
je trouve que c'est quand même une idée
qui était une très bonne idée car en
effet il faut adapter les militaires
autant d'aujourd'hui il faut vivre avec
son temps
alors par exemple à côté de vous il ya
une nouvelle recrue qui dans deux jours
rentrer à la caserne qu'elle sortira
après avec cette nouvelle tenue qu est
ce que vous les conseillez écouter en
matière de mode j'essaie d'être logique
une nouvelle recrue sa 20 ans et
aujourd'hui les jeunes de 20 ans sa vie
comme la veille sa vision jean ba je
pense qu'un des matériaux auxquels il
faudra penser jean
je crois qu'il faut assouplir puis faut
aussi un peu un peu découragé
l'agression je crois que si le soldat
nous nous habillons de façon un peu un
peu un peu drôle soldats imprimions qui
lui tirait dessus
il eut déclaré la guerre c'est pas
possible alors je me suis permis de
dessiner deux ou trois tenues de
vêtements de vos pour les soldats
français
c'est pas la guerre en dentelle tout à
fait mais c'est ça peut être dujardin
primé ça peut être du velours côtelé
imprimé à l'époque la prise et le moan
concours les candidats sont libres de
choisir le tissu la ligne la couleur
mais aussi la coiffure
je pense qu'ils ne vont pas s'en priver
plus sérieux maintenant lorsque le
nouvel uniforme de sortie sur a choisi
il faudra le fabriquer c'est une
évidence retour alors à la procédure
habituelle pour les vêtements de l'armée
c'est à dire passage par le bureau
d'études spécialisé
exactement comme si c'était une nouvelle
automobile ou un nouvel avion à partir
de la réception de la décision du
ministre ici nous selon le cas où nous
mettrons à plat le prototype que nous
dans su saisir que nous le
décortiqueront pour pour en déterminer
les mesures exactes ou nous
reconstruirons ici dans l'atelier un
prototype et à partir de ce prototype
nous ferons le
le patronage c'est ce que font ces
messieurs donc vos bureaux ne vont pas
choisir les tissus mais par contre vous
allez en déterminer la quantité
nécessaire
oui nous allons déterminer la quantité
que nous aurons à données fournies aux
industriels pour chaque taille des
tissus à fabre détenu à fabriquer bien
maintenant parlons des délais dans
combien de temps est ce que on peut
espérer voir ces tenues de sortie de
l'armée de terre dans la russie dix ans
dans le meilleur des cas techniquement
on ne peut pas obtenir industriellement
les premières tenues deux en avant deux
ans après la décision du mini c'est à
dire très près 1980 finalement c'est à
dire ça fait très près de 1980 quand du
concours le 27 juin prochain que son
côté gus notre dessinateur propose cinq
costumes rétro futuriste un écologique
recruteur et un costume de pratiquer
quelque chose me dit que la quatrième
proposition à ses chances auprès de
l'état major et bien le groupe d'étude
violents ces informations il n'y a pas
de rapport d'ailleurs avec ce n'est de
voir le groupe d'étude violence et
informations créées à l'initiative de
michel poniatowski se met en place
georges leroy directeur adjoint de
l'information à antenne 2 y siégera la
violence et la télévision
c'est justement le problème qu'évoque le
ministre de l'intérieur dans une
interview exclusive accordée cette
semaine à notre confrère télé poche
donc vous voyez d'ailleurs derrière moi
la couverture il y affirme en
particulier monsieur koné toschi qu'il
n'est pas question dans son esprit de
chercher à censurer les moyens
d'information et cet ampli le temps
aujourd'hui variable c'est le cas de
dire plutôt frais avec des températures
ne dépassant guère 12° sauf quand le
soleil brille et ce qui a été le cas en
particulier sur la région parisienne
une partie de la journée demain matin le
ciel sera très nuageux avec des pluies
faibles de la normandie et de la
bretagne aux pays bas ce sont les autres
régions il fera un peu plus frais avec
des gelées au lever du jour et des
brouillards locaux suivi d'éclaircies
la corse des averses pourront se
produire l'après-midi le temps pluvieux
s'étendra à toute la france
le midi méditerranéen et tente épargnés
tant mieux pour ceux qui habitent ces
régions tandis qu'une amélioration
débutera quand même au voisinage de la
manche il devrait donc faire un peu plus
beau après nous voilà ce que nous avions
à vous dire ce soir nous vous souhaitons
une bonne soirée maurice werther en fin
de programme pour notre dernière édition
que vous dit à dom